[MUSIC PLAYING]
LINDSAY JEAN THOMSON:
Before I tell you
what I'm about to tell you,
a little bit of context.
I grew up in a very small
and conservative town,
and I was the girl who wore a
"this is what a feminist looks
like" T-shirt to school.
So knowing that about me,
one day, many years later,
I'm hanging out in the park
with my best friend Kim.
We are flying kites and
drinking beers, like we do.
And seemingly out of
nowhere I say, hey,
would you want to start like a
monthly women's speakers series
with me?
And because Kim is
the kind of person
who is such an
enthusiastic yes to life,
she was in, and that's how
Women Catalysts was born.
How many of you
have heard of us?
Or been to an event?
Great.
We are on a mission to inspire
the catalyst in every woman
through powerful storytelling,
lasting community, and the best
resources.
We started Women Catalysts
for a lot of reasons.
And I'm going to talk about
one in particular today.
The power of shifting the
storylines that hold us back.
These are actual headlines
from around the time
we started Women Catalysts.
Or they're supposed to be.
But things happen, right?
Lean in.
Don't lean in, lean out.
Ask for what you want, but
make sure you do it just right,
and you're probably not
going to get it anyways.
How do you feel when you
hear stories like these?
Yeah.
They're problematic for
a lot of reasons, right?
I feel really frustrated,
but worse than that,
I feel disempowered.
Like, I could try to follow all
of that contradictory advice,
but would it even matter?
So what would matter?
What can I do?
I can start with the
stories that I tell myself,
and that I share
with my community.
And the reality is, I know
a lot of amazing women
who defy those headlines.
I'm guessing you do too.
Women who start
companies and nonprofits.
Women who make art
and write books.
And who do all of these
incredible things,
not out of some
trite dated notion
of having it all,
but because they care
and because they have something
of value to offer the world.
Over the past year I've
gotten to interview
many of these women for our
speaker series, Catalyst
Conversations.
Women like Zakiya Harris, who
not only started Hack the Hood,
but is also a mom, a musician,
an educator, and so much more.
Really, I have no idea
how she does it all.
Women like Elle Luna, who left
her job in tech to make art,
and inspired millions of
people around the world
with her story, "The
Crossroads of Should and Must."
I'm guessing some of you
have heard of that one.
Yeah.
These are the kinds of
stories that I want to tell,
because they make me feel
like I can do it too.
How do you feel when you
hear stories like these?
Yeah, they're a lot
more empowering, right?
I'm really honored to say
that over the past year
we have accomplished so much.
And it was just a dream.
And I'm sharing all
of this with you
because, where might
you be in a year?
What story will you
tell, and who will you
inspire with your words
and with your actions?
In the last year, we have
gone from doing events in San
Francisco, to New York, and LA.
With the help of our
small but mighty team
we've raised over
$15,000 for nonprofits
doing really important
work in our communities.
And most recently we launched
the Catalyst Collective,
our online community and
group coaching program
for aspiring change makers.
So again, where might
you be in a year?
What story will you
tell, and who might you
inspire with your words
and with your actions?
Because the stories
we tell matter.
What you do matters.
You matter.
What change do you want
to see in the world?
Take fierce action with great
love, and be a catalyst, too.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]